[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à tous ravis de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui paris saclay tv va
vous donner envie de reprendre des
études
nous allons déjà célébrer les 70 ans du
campus de gif-sur-yvette 70 ans déjà que
le cnrs a pris ses quartiers ici à paris
saclay une exposition retrace cette
histoire on vous y emmène dans un
instant ce campus il a permis de
développer des synergies entre les
différentes disciplines mais aussi entre
le monde de la recherche et de
l'entreprise comment aller plus loin
comment accélérer cette dynamique
université paris saclay y réfléchit nous
verrons comment embrasser une carrière
scientifique intégrer deux autres écoles
ce n'est pas toujours très évident pour
certains jeunes les cordées de la
réussite veulent lever les obstacles ni
là c'était paris saclay s'associe à ce
dispositif avec des journées portes
ouvertes à suivre notre reportage et
enfin notre agenda tous les grands
rendez vous à ne pas manquer dans les
semaines qui viennent ce sera bien sûr à
la fin de cette émission
nous voici donc à gif-sur-yvette gif sur
yvette qui célèbre les 70 ans du campus
du cnrs première brique historique du
grand pôle scientifique de paris saclay
c'est en effet le cnrs qui le premier
s'est installé ici les grandes écoles
ont suivi les liens se sont fait très
vite une exposition revient sur cette
histoire et comme promis
paris saclay tv with your man
[Musique]
cette exposition elle vise à revenir sur
70 ans d'histoire d'un campus
scientifique campus du cnra de
gif-sur-yvette au travers des
différentes activités qui ont été
accomplis tout au long de cette décennie
de manière à rendre accessible un
certain nombre d'éléments au grand
public alors faire comprendre à la vie
le scientifique mais aussi humaines
techniques
les échanges qui ont pu avoir lieu sur
sur ses sites de recherche qui existe
maintenant depuis depuis la libération
depuis 1946
le cnra c'est un petit peu pionnier dans
cette histoire puisque c'est le premier
établissement à s'installer en vallée de
chevreuse mais très vite il est rejoint
par d'autres établissements notamment au
premier lieu par le cea puis les
universités les grandes écoles enfin de
toute l'histoire qu'on connaît ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est à la
fois un mouvement qui s'est fait de
manière peut-être un petit peu décousu
d'un établissement à l'autre mais très
vite les liens se sont faits et
notamment des liens du point de vue
humain parce que ba la science à ça
repose avant tout sur des femmes et des
hommes et ce sont eux qui créent la
scion sont eux qui créent les liens
entre les établissements et aujourd'hui
encore il y a eu sur ce site un certain
nombre d'événements marquants de tout
point de vue que ce soit scientifique
que ce soit humain des visites de
politique donc c'est vraiment un site ya
eu une une vie foisonnante tout au tout
au long de cette période que ce soit
l'acquisition de 1946 qui implique des
personnalités comme frédéric joliot
curie ou
ou d'autres que ce soit les années 60
que j'ai eu l'occasion d'évoquer dans la
conférence qui précédait et puis l'élan
qui a été donnée à ce moment là autour
de la recherche que ce soit les années
les plus récentes et les découvertes qui
a été fait à j fossiles et les progrès
dans le domaine des médicaments dans
d'autres domaines donc c'est vraiment
une vie foisonnante qu'on aurait
beaucoup de mal a résumé en très peu de
temps et qui mérite et doux à la
rédaction d'un ouvrage en parallèle des
expositions tous les événements qui
pouvait avoir lieu pour ses 70 ans
l'objectif de deux ouvrages c'était de
revenir sur 70 ans d'histoire mais c'est
aussi un moyen de réfléchir à tout ce
qui va se produire par la suite c'est en
fait c'est un coup d'oeil dans le
rétroviseur
l'ouvragé l'exposition et d'autres
éléments un coup d'oeil dans le rétro
pour permettre de construire la suite de
cette histoire qui l'espère je le
souhaite je le pense même sera aussi
rayonnante que les pages précédentes
[Musique]
développer des synergies entre la
recherche et l'industrie cette question
était au coeur d'un séminaire organisé à
hec par le conseil académique de
l'université paris saclay une journée de
débats cette question est un seul
objectif comment innover au sein du
campus
on voit tout cela avec nathalie
populaire vice-présidente du conseil
académique
[Musique]
le conseil académique de l'université
paris saclay a pris l'initiative de
monter un séminaire pour exploiter les
synergies qui peuvent exister sur le
plateau de saclay entre la science la
formation la recherche d'une part et
l'industrie de l'autre de l'autre parent
donc la synergie
elle se fait pas tout seul il faut une
incitation une incitation au réseau et
savoir quels quel type d'incitation on
peut proposer pour que ça fonctionne et
comment les acteurs eux mêmes doivent
s'organiser au jour le jour
pour réaliser ces synergies et et
innover innover davantage sur le plateau
de saclay
cette journée est bâtie à partir de 7
cette question de questionnements qui
peuvent s'adresser
chercheurs académiques ou aux personnes
de terrain
[Musique]
sur le plateau de saclay il ya déjà un
écosystème d'innovation qui a été créée
avec des investissements publics des
aides publiques notamment on peut citer
la sat qui est une société des deux
transferts technologiques qui fait
partie du réseau national des sacs qui
va aider des projets innovants à trouver
leur place il y à aussi dans le réseau
pépite nationale le réseau qui associé à
saclay caps est ce qui pour aider les
étudiants qui ont une idée pour créer
leur start up on va les aider donc on
fait passer comme ça de la formation
jusqu'à la création d'entreprise est
certes up
il y à de nombreuses incubateur il ya
des fab lab et il y à des fonds des
fonds d'investissements des fonds du
financement
et comme là qui vient d'être mis en eau
mis en place avec 150 millions d'euros
de financement pour les idées innovantes
et les projets innovants sur le plateau
donc tout ça c'est en train de se mettre
en place mais il faut il faut continuer
à travailler et à augmenter j'irai
encore les synergies pour devenir
vraiment le cluster innovants au niveau
mondial le campus paris saclay ni sur
les synergies il faut les entretenir il
faut les développer
comment l'université paris saclay paris
sur l'interdisciplinarité
découvrez sans plus attendre le rôle de
la msh la maison des sciences de l'homme
grâce à son directeur stéphane aux
proportions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une journée très important pour la
communauté shs de l'université paris
saclay une communauté qui est nombreuse
et qui a un potentiel de recherche
absolument formidable la question posée
est celle de l'éparpillement des forces
donc il faut trouver la manière de
fédérer ses forces autour d'angers
scientifique majeure un terrain compte
de la spécificité du site
l'université paris saclay cette
université d'un mondial et dans laquelle
les essais chez son rôle à jouer
important elles peuvent profiter des
l'environnement scientifique tout à fait
exceptionnel pour cette raison la maison
des sciences de l'homme que j'ai
l'honneur de diriger et comme ça comme
stratégie des portes et
l'interdisciplinarité non seulement
entre les sss rôle historique pour les
un message le tel qu'il a été défini par
fernand braudel aux années 60 mais aussi
l'interdisciplinarité avec les autres
sciences et donc c'est un message à une
vocation particulière qui profitent de
la spécificité du site
cette spécificité et vient aussi du fait
que les industriels sont très présents
alors il est très important pour notre
message aussi dépenser les interactions
avec le monde industriel et pensez aussi
à la valorisation des recherches et ses
fils on n'est pas là pour jouer les
rôles des sciences comme caution des
ciels des autres sciences sciences
humaines et sociales en comme caution
des autres sciences mais on peut
participer à réflexion en amont qui
sur des questions shs avant d'orienter
les recherches dans les autres sciences
et les applications technologiques
[Musique]
mais n'oublions pas les étudiants il
n'est pas toujours facile d'envisager de
hautes études surtout quand on vit dans
des quartiers prioritaires
les cordées de la réussite veulent
ouvrir des portes et propose à ses
jeunes des tuteurs l'université paris
saclay s'associe à ce dispositif est
organisée une journée formations et
métiers
notre équipe était sur place
[Musique]
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir à
l'université d'evry
donc aujourd'hui l'université d'evry
accueille le premier événement donc que
l'on a fait sur la corde et mutualisé
paris-saclay d'accord des paris saclay a
démarré le 4 novembre
chacun avait des formats un peu
différent il a on a décidé de lancer
cette expérience ensemble le 21 janvier
dans le cadre de la semaine nationale
des cordées de la réussite
donc ces années une journée de formation
et métiers donc l'objectif c'est de
rassembler des jeunes qui sont tutoré
dans différents établissements
l'université d'evry mais aussi
polytechnique hec un groupe paristech et
ils vont pouvoir soit assister à des
conférences qui vont présenter l'iut
l'université les écoles d'ingénieurs de
commerce ou alors rencontrer des
professionnels qui vont leur parler de
leur métier non des professionnels du
secteur de la logistique des ressources
humaines
un vétérinaire nous avons aussi un
journaliste et donc ça va permettre
effectivement de découvrir tous ces
éléments-là poser des questions dans des
cadres pour les rendez-vous métiers qui
sont relativement informel et puis ce
qui me paraît important c'est aussi
c'est un événement mutualisé qui vient
se rajouter à ce que chacun fait comme
événement comme action qu'il propose
dans le cadre de s'accorder particulière
et là l'idée c'est de créer petit à
petit un certain nombre d'événements où
toutes les écoles et établissements vont
pouvoir participer ensemble et donc je
trouve ça très riche pour les élèves de
voir qu'il ya des gens de partout qui
sont là pour les leur permettre de céder
de les aider dans leur orientation
le dispositif deux cordées de la
réussite c'est un dispositif national
qui a pour objectif de favoriser l'accès
à l'enseignement supérieur des jeunes
issus de milieux modestes et quartier
prioritaires c'est-à-dire politique de
la ville est en fête
il s'agit en fait de tutorat étudiants
vers des collégiens et des lycéens de
ces quartiers prioritaires
sous forme d'ateliers à l'heure
d'ouverture culturelle et scientifique
de méthodologie de travail sur
l'orientation et les métiers etc
un des objectifs c'est justement de
facilité en fait le suivi de ces jeunes
puisque l'intérêt quand même ses devoirs
sur un an de tutorat en fait comment ils
vont évoluer et si vraiment il va y
avoir un accès aux études supérieures et
du coup on verra dans un an
donc on espère vous revoir dans un an
pour vous raconter l'évolution de ceux
de ce projet et il faut savoir quand
même que le lancement s'est fait avec
l'ami la secrétaire d'état à la ville
qui madame geoffroy et qui donc soutient
ce projet de manière vraiment importante
et maintenant notre agenda les rendez
vous à ne surtout pas rater dans les
semaines qui viennent on commence avec
un concours il faut trouver une
signature au cluster paris saclay à vous
de jouer et de faire vos propositions
sur la page facebook du proto 204
n'hésitez pas à participer et surtout à
voter pour vos signatures préférez vous
avez jusqu'au 28 février 2010 est la
onzième édition de tech'innove c'est le
23 février 2010 est à paris orly une
journée 100% business et innovation vous
êtes lycéen étudiant vous ne savez pas
encore quelles filières choisir
l'université paris sud organise des
journées portes ouvertes du 22 février
2010 7 au 18 mars 2010 est pour vous
faire mieux connaître les formations
proposées par l'université et enfin le
20 février 2010 est le comité de suivi
de chantier du quartier de moulins se
retrouvent vous êtes bien sûr les
bienvenus
voilà pour cet agenda c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de paris
saclay tv d'ici là restez connectés sur
eps.fr et sur tv fil 78 bien sûr
[Musique]